[موسيقى]
اوكرانيا تتقدم بطلب جديد للنيتوف فهل
سيتم قبوله والكرم بن الامريكيين قطعتم
الغصن الذي تجلسون عليه ولا مجال للعوده
وموسكو تستعرض بعضلات العسكريه في المحيط
الهادئ وتامر اسطولها برفع حاله التاهب
القصوى فما الذي يجري وبولندا تتصادم
عسكريا مع روسيا وموسكو تتوعد بالرد
والاتحاد الاوروبي للصين انتم اخر املنا
وبكين تحضر بالاسلحه الحيه والصواريخ
ورائحه حرب جديده تفوح في الارجاء مجنون
كوريا الشماليه يستعيد بعضا من عنفوان
صواريخ وواشنطن تحضر لرد عسكري والمقاومه
تلجم المحتل برد صاعق واليمن السعيد يقول
للحرب باي باي
يتجاهل المحتجين ويمضي في قراره والنتيجه
كارثيه ومقتدى الصدر يعلن قرار عراقي
تاريخي جمدت دما في عروق مناصري تقدم روسي
وانسحاب اوكراني
تضاعفت الضربات والاله القوات الروسيه من
كل حدب وصوب في الاراضي الاوكرانيه
واوكرانيا لا حول لها ولا قوه وناوي
الدفاع الروسيه تصرح ان قوات فاجنر تواصل
عملياتها العسكريه القتاليه المكثفه بهدف
اخراج القوات الاوكرانيه من الاحياء
المركزيه لمدينه باخموت وتواصل القوات
الروسيه من جميع الاتجاهات الضغطه
للاستيلاء على مدينه بخموت شرق اوكرانيا
فيما يبدو ان الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد بات
وشيكا فهل هو كذلك وكاله
بتاكيدها ان بعض حلفاء اوكرانيا
الاوروبيين يشككون في احتمالات هجومها
المضاد المتوقع ولا يقتنعون بامكانيه حدوث
اختراق كبيره هو اعلان لفشل الهجوم قبل
حتى ان يبدا وهنا تعلن كييف ان القوات
الروسيه تنفذ يوميا في بخموته من اربعين
الى خمسين عمليه اقتحام وخمسه مئه عمليه
قصفه الاوكران لا يكادون يصحون من ضربه
حتى تنزل عليهم التاليه فياال صعوبه
اوضاعهم حيث اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
عن تصفيه اكثر من 500 وخمسه وخمسين جنديا
اوكرانيا وتدمير ستين
الى ذلك قالت الاستخبارات البريطانيه ان
القوات الاوكرانيه
الانسحاب من بعض الاراضي في مدينه بخموت
مشيره الى تحسن التعاون بين وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه ومجموعه فاجنر ليشير وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني الا انه لا بدل عن انضمام بلاده
الى حلف الناتو ومن حاله الياس الاوكرانيه
ننتقل الى بصيص الامل الاوروبي حيث بولندا
انها ستسلم المزيد من طائرات ميج تسعه
وعشرين الى اوكرانيا بينما اقر مجلس
الاتحاد الاوروبي تخصيص مليار يورو بهدف
دعم القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه وذكر
المجلس ان المبلغ سيساعد في تعويض الدول
التي تزود اوكرانيا من مخزوناتها فهي لها
من خطه ذكيه الدول الاوروبيه تدعم نفسها
بنفسها ولكن تحت مسمى دعم اوكرانيا عن اي
دعم تتحدثون فلم يكون امام اوروبا الا
تحميل الصين مسؤوليات كبيره فيما يتعلق
بالحرب في اوكرانيا حيث قال منسق شؤون
الخارجيه بالاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيفوريل انه
سيكون من الصعب الحفاظ على الثقه اذا لم
تساهم الصين في البحث عن حل سياسي استنادا
الى انسحاب روسيا من الاراضي الاوكرانيه
لننتقل الى المحيط الهادئ والذي لم يعد
هادئا بعد تدريبات رو مفاجئه بدات بناء
على اوامر الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
هنا وزير الدفاع الروسي يقول ان اسطول
المحيط لادئ كان في حاله تاهب قصوى مضيفا
ان الهدف الرئيسي من هذا التمرين هو بناء
قدره القوات المسلحه على مهام صد عدوان
محتمل من اتجاه المحيط والبحر بحسب تعبيره
ليعود شويجو ويوجه تصريحا شديدا لهجه نحو
بولندا بقوله ان بولندا ركزت وحده عسكريه
جاده على الحدود مع بيلاروسيا وهو امر لا
ينبغي نسيانه ايضا فهل نسي البولنديون
تحذيرات موسكو ام انهم يجازفون بمواجهه
الدب الروسي حال بولندا هو ذات الحال في
استونيا فجميعهم يتحرش بروسيا حيث ذكرت
الخدمه الصحفيه بالمقر الرئيسي لقوات
الدفاع الاستونيه بان وحده من مشاه
البحريه الام وصلت الى استونيا للتدريب
المشترك والمساهمه في التدريبات المقبله
لمده اربعه اشهر فيما يسمى بمناوراتي
عاصفه الربيع واسعه النطاق ومن الحروب
الحاليه الى معارك الاوراق الماليه حيث
قال وزير الخارجيه
انه لا مجال للعوده فالولايات المتحده
قطعت الغصن الذي كانت تجلس عليه ويقصد
الدولار الامريكي موضحا ان هروب الدول من
الاعتماد على الدولار والاعتماد اكثر على
عملاتها في التبادلات التجاريه اصبح نهجا
لا رجوع فيه وعلى مستوى الطاقه كشفت وكاله
الطاقه الدوليه ان صادرات روسيا النفطيه
قفزت الى اعلى مستوى في نحو ثلاث سنوات
برغم العقوبات الغربيه فمن يعاقب من اذا
وبعيدا عن الواقع صرح ممثل مساعد وزيره
الخارجيه الامريكيه بان القوات
ستصبح اكثر عددا وتقدما في اوروبا بعد
تركيا وستلعب دورا مهما في نظام الامن
الاوروبي ليرد بان ذلك سيحدث ان بقي شيء
اسمه جيش اوكراني حينها اصلا
التنين الصيني يطلق صواريخها الاجواء
مشحونه بما يكفي والتنين الصيني بكامل
استعداده وتايوان حابسه لانفاسها وبعد
ثلاثه ايام من انتهاء المناورات البحريه
التي اجرتها بكين حول جزيره تايوان اعلنت
وزاره الدفاع الصينيه انها اجرت اختبار
اعتراض صواريخ في منتصف المسار من الارض
داخل اراضيا وحققت هدفا لاختبار المنشود
بحسب السوشير لكن ما هو الهدف يا اصحاب
العيون الضيقه نعم تتسارع التطورات
العسكريه والدبلوماسيه في قضيه مضيق
تايوان حيث صدرت مواقف تحذر من خطر
التصايد في تلك المنطقه فمن العاصمه
الصينيه قالت وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه
عسكري في مضيق تايوان سيشكل سيناريو
كارثيا للعالم باسره لاسيما ان 50% من
التجاره العالميه تمر عبر بينما اكد منسق
السياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي ان
موقفا الاتحاد ثابت وواضح تجاه الالتزام
بسياسه الصين الواحده ودعا الجميع الى
تجنب الاستفزازات وضمان احترام القانون
الدولي بهدف الوصول الى نظام دولي يسود
فيه التعاون على المواجهه
الاحداث والتطورات
نشرت التلفزيون الرسمي في كوريا الشماليه
مشاهد حيه لاطلاق صاروخ باليسي عبر
للقارات باشراف الزعيم
هناك دانه الولايات المتحده بشده اطلاق
كوريا الشماليه الصاروخ البالستي طويل
المدى معتبره انه يشكل انتهاكا فاضحا
لكثير من قرارات
بلا داع ويهدد بزعزعه الامن في المنطقه
ليحذر البيت الابيض من ان الولايات
المتحده ستتخذ كل الاجراءات اللازمه لضمان
امنها وامنحني فتيها كوريا الجنوبيه
واليابان تعهد رئيس حركه حماس في قطاع غزه
يحيى السنوار بتدخل المقاومه لمؤازره
وحمايه المصلين في الحرم القدسي وقال
السنوار ان الامريكيين والاوروبيين والعرب
نصحوا اسرائيل بلجم جنودها في المسجد
الاقصى لكنها لم تستمع فجاءها رد صاعق
التعبير في قرار مفاجئ زعيم التيار الصدري
في العراق مقتدى الصدر يصدم انصاره باعلان
تجميد التيار الصدري عاما كاملا قال وزير
الخارجيه التركي مولود جاج اوغلو ان متفق
مع نظيره المصري سامح شكري على العمل
لخارطه طريق تقود ليبيا الى الانتخابات
بدات في اليمن عمليه لتبادل مئات الاسرى
بين اطراف النزاع في بارقه امل جديده تدفع
الجهود الدبلوماسيه الهادفه لوضع النزاع
الدم على طريق الحل واعلنت اللجنه الدوليه
للصليب الاحمر بدا عمليه تبادل للاسرى بين
الحكومه اليمنيه والحوثيين التي تشمل نحو
900 محتجز وتستمر لعده ايام صادق المجلس
الدستوري الفرنسي على البنود الاساسيه
لقانون رفع سن التقاعد وقر المجلس
الدستوري معظم اصلاحات نظام التقاعد بما
في ذلك رفع سن التقاعد من 62 الى 64 عاما
والمحتجون يملاون الشوارع الفرنسيه فهل
تعم الفوضى فرنسا بعد هذا القرار الدب
الروسي يشعل المحيط الهادئ برايكم ما هي
وجهه اسطول موسكو البحري
[موسيقى]